a Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance the President of the United
States has admitted that the Russians
meddled in the election that put him in
power and he has blamed his predecessor
in essence we're not stopping him and he
has admitted to intimidating the FBI
director who was investigating his
treachery and he has resumed his veiled
threats of intimidation against the
special counsel now investigating his
treachery and yet this quote president
unquote has not yet been removed and
arrested we are appeasing Trump the mind
reels in our democracy if not dead is in
suspended animation because the
Republican Party is now actively
shielding this treasonous megalomaniac
because he will sign whatever they put
in front of him and their actions should
be identified for what they are being
accessories after the fact to the worst
set of crimes in American history we are
appeasing Trump the nation which should
be in the streets holding a general
strike fighting to restore the rule of
law that is dissolving in front of its
eyes is instead uh turley divided or
distracted or both Republican
legislators wholly owned by corporations
are dismantling the already porous
health care net in order to fund tax
breaks for the wealthiest and greediest
bastards among us even though every
group from their own constituents to
every hospital and every insurance
organization opposes the action the
president's sycophantic base is happy
because while a few of them may have
noticed this society is still hitting
them in the head they look with perverse
joy at the reality that this society is
now hitting women and minorities harder
we are appeasing Trump the elected
Democrats who should be the voice of
resistance against every legislative
dismemberment by Trump and his gang as
well as the base for all the defenses of
the democracy are instead jockeying for
position and cynically calculating if
keeping Trump in office to next year
will give them a better chance of
election cynically calculating if it's
better to let the country
burn until autumn 2018 rather than
putting out the fire now these Democrats
are offset by others who argue one vote
in one special election means they need
to ease up on the Russia thing and must
stand for something as if the Russia
thing did not threaten everything we
hold dear and standing for a restoration
of representative government was not
something we are appeasing Trump and the
media is obsessed not with the lies of a
president who is gifted only at lying
and news conferences by his lying
spokespeople that contain no news no
truth no reality no morality which is
spun by cretinous deceivers who make the
farcical propaganda of the infamous
Iraqi Baghdad Bob looked like the
revealed word the media is obsessed not
by recognizing war has been declared on
it and Trump's goons are playing them
like the proverbial two-dollar banjo the
media is obsessed that the White House
won't let them record the press
briefings that are nothing but lies and
instead of getting up and walking out
and no longer participating in this
desecration of freedom of the press they
stay there and still report the lies and
still put the White House Liars on the
sunday shows and still pander to the
Trump audience that we're not watching
them are not watching them and will not
be watching them and calculating only
how the lack of a live feed from the
White House pressroom will impact their
ratings instead of how the lack of
truths from the White House press room
will impact whether their children live
in freedom or slavery we are appeasing
trump resist because these people are
not going to do it for you peace